Roger stone come on in Roger a gym may
or may not be defecating so you'll have
to give him a moment but you know we all
have to empty our bowels at certain
times of the day it happens doesn't it
Roger
too much information well you know I
want I just want you to be informed I
don't want you coming in here and
feeling like an outsider you're you're
one of us after all
I always feel at home here good good
welcome Jim I informed Roger you may or
may not be defecating no no I had to
make a phone call to a doctor that I was
I was late on my phone call oh [ __ ]
he went he went like this I assume that
means the the anal cavity is right you
know it's what he's talking or it's a
white supremacist hand sign I'm not sure
which he does have a white supremacist
doc oh the a-ok that's right that's
right
that's his bull is it bull yeah not
since the white supremacist hand I don't
know that they have one oh this comes
from Donald J Trump he does it when he's
speaking oh he does it all the time he's
not a white supremacist all the time
most certainly not good good and by the
way I was watching your pronouns and you
said they instead of we my credit to you
you are also not a white supremacist I'm
most definitely not I will never the
president Richard Nixon who gave us
affirmative action desegregated the
public schools and created the office of
minority business enterprise I mean you
have a tattoo of the guy in your back I
do true right his civil rights record is
actually quite strong because of the
circumstances of his 68 election where
he had Wallace running to his right and
Humphrey running to his left he finessed
the civil rights question in the
election no question about so why does
he go then look at the record after a
four years pretty good why does he get
lumped into this legged like he's an
evil man
well Watergate has destroyed any legacy
he might have had reached the strategic
arms limitation with the Soviets
he ended the Vietnam War he opens the
door to China he saves Israel
unilaterally in the 1973 Yom Kippur War
with an airlift of lethal aid when their
backs are against the sea he also makes
huge mistakes the ignominious failed
racist war on drugs probably the biggest
mistake taking us off to Goldstein well
taping himself is not smart either and
it's weird like these guys like when
you're taping your
when you know you're taping yourself and
for a while you just forget because
right of course the problem is that both
JFK and LBJ tapes themselves what
happens is apes that they remembered
they were on tape today that's why you
could hey you can hear Lyndon Johnson
saying to J Edgar Hoover uh so is uh was
anybody gonna shoot at me in Dallas uh
because he knows he's it's on tape right
or the tape well I asked you to do you
think are you surprised at microphone
taped Trump not in the slightest you're
not isn't that like a huge allurement
this on the show isn't it like a a mega
breach of confidentiality
I thought your client printful I trying
to think in life that people who are
dumb and know they're dumb are not a
problem it's the people who are dumb and
think they're smart is the problem and
who are you referring to 2006 I am
referring in this case to Michael Kohn I
see who I've known for 15 years have you
known he's dumb for 15 years yes how
long did it take my realize I've sat in
meetings with him and listened to some
of the dumb things that he said and
they're stupid how long did it take you
to realize he was stupid not very long
you know but not only that but he lied
to me on a number of occasions so I know
that he's a liar what did he lie to you
about in 2012 he set up a draft Trump
website told us it had tremendous
traffic and that he had compiled a list
of email addresses from that which would
be beneficial down the road if Trump
decided to run I could ever could get my
hands on that list you know why because
it didn't exist lies he was one but
taping a client as an attorney yeah
really
under what circumstances can you tell
yourself I mean he was obviously doing
it to protect himself for what he said
but like how can you tell yourself that
that's okay
I guess he thought it was clever I don't
know do you think he should be disbarred
I need to know a lot more about the case
and then we don't least at this point we
don't know what it is he has on tape
what do we don't know what it is that he
has in his files who just know it we
have known I listened to the tape that
they released incomprehensible and it
didn't seem very encode and both of them
are confused but confusion can meet even
more it's kind of interesting because
John Dean who was on CNN the other night
just before me you know him he's the guy
who
and pushed and then covered up the
Watergate break-in and then blamed it on
everyone else
I see uh and I wrote a book on this
called Nixon secrets makes a pretty good
case but he published a book which he
said were all of the transcribed tapes
from the from the Nixon Watergate White
House so I read his book when I found
out there were three conversations
missing March 16th 17th and 22nd of 1973
that's because you can hear Dean leading
Nixon right into the Watergate cover-up
so he didn't include those but it
sounded very much like the cone tape two
guys talking past each other sir I need
to talk to you about you know that thing
which thing that's a no-no that other
thing I mean these guys it's an
absurdity you know one point in the tape
Cohen says to Trump why would I take
care of the finance and Trump says what
financing what are you talking about did
Trump know you think that he was being
recorded I doubt it was anything he
suspected maybe maybe a guy like that
he's also talking in code is like maybe
you prepare yourself to always know that
that's a possible I think that he is
very savvy about that I mean here's
somebody this is why this idea of him
having any you know alert activities in
Russia are outside the question he would
say to me always assume you're being
watched if you call abroad used to
assume you're being filmed and they're
all watching you whoever he sends his
kid to do it instead no again
the meeting at Trump Tower perfectly
legal what would be the point well let
me ask you this we were talking about
the meeting because if I want your
opinion on what the hell this Rudy
Giuliani is doing because it just seems
like the more media appearances he does
the more he's losing his mind I don't
know what he's talking about half the
time it doesn't seem like even Fox News
what he fuddled he does but is that part
of the strategy well I don't agree with
your analysis although he did confuse me
on the Michael Kohn thing when he tried
to explain it right he's talking about
two meetings one meeting three meeting
yeah all three said spider I'm at the
meeting yeah it was not a good show
Donald Trump jr. has a meeting with a
woman
Russian lawyer at Trump Tower she meets
with the people at fusion GPS who wrote
the phony dossier before the meeting and
after the meeting
that's called briefing and
debriefing question miss village kaya
where did you get your visa
show us your visa don't know where her
visa came from the visa she applied for
in New York was it was denied by the US
attorney here which means somebody in
Washington approved her visa what was
she doing in the country what was she
here for other than to have that meeting
the purpose of the meeting appears to me
was to be able to say we had a meeting
not not the substance of the meeting
where nothing improper or illegal
happens the meeting turns out to be a
waste of time but the meeting itself is
not illegal the purposes of the meeting
I think are clearer and clearer but why
is Giuliani going on TV and talking
about a second meeting and like giving
all this information that nobody's
asking and and it seems like nobody
knows what he's talking about I think
he's been effective on the on the
question of the partnership part
partisanship of the Muller Enterprise
and he has been realistic about the fact
that the president no client should sit
down for an open-ended interview with a
prosecutor when there's a possibility of
perjury or obstruction of justice on the
table
isn't it nuts a little sorry Jim isn't
it a little nuts for Giuliani he'd said
like yesterday he's on TV and he goes
number one there was no collusion number
two collusions not illegal anyway so
you're going like what was there no
collusion or are you excusing it well
he's right but the point is he's right
on both points look I made the same
mistake at one point on Twitter I said a
meeting with Julian Assange would not be
illegal he's a journalist and meeting
with him is not a crime not that I met
with him because I didn't write that's
allegedly I believe it was dinner time
and there was a one reporter with The
Wall Street Journal who wanted to know
what could the dinner have taken place
via Skype but didn't know really
actually if we did that then he would be
a breakfast and I would be a dancer yeah
yeah we also didn't happen there either
that's the kind of irresponsible crazy
they supporting you get from people like
Shelby holiday of the Wall Street
Journal it's in the media is really
panicking too like the head of the times
are saying that Trump is being which I
think that the media is kind of shooting
themselves what are they saying just
that that he's causing a very dangerous
in
because he's calling everything fake
news but meanwhile people getting the
news from Twitter that's half the reason
I'm discrediting the press yeah but you
know as if that as if they're always
right and as if they're a perfect
arbiter of everything that is now I
think they deserve the criticism this
whole idea though that every reporter at
the New York Times is is biased and
every reporter at the Washington Post
but it doesn't work that way there are
good reporters they're just trying to do
their job who are intellectually honest
there are others who have a point of
view and it weaves into their reporting
was that more the editors don't tell the
editors have the final say-so like the
tone of the editor will kind of dictate
the tone of the paper exactly which
editor at the New York Times is a
registered Republican could they produce
his name please the answer will be none
right I see I see what do you think that
and this I'm more just playing devil's
advocate but the argument I think with
people that think that Trump is
discrediting the media is that he
announces things like CNN Washington
Post New York New York Times as fake
news but Fox News for example is like
the beacon of truth Fox News clearly has
a bias one way the same way CNN in New
York Times clearly have a bias one way
but Trump seems to like the media that
has a bias towards him no I would
actually argue if you analyze CNN 24
hours a day while there are some shows
that have a bias towards him there's
plenty of anti Trump comment there as
well Diamond Fox News Fox yeah but also
Fox is clearly in some kind of
transition mm-hmm
with the sales of Disney and so on and
with kimberly guilfoyle the single best
thing they had going for them leaving
yeah so what do you know how did Kristin
Davis get dragged into this she ran for
governor a few years ago or wanted to
run I think she had asked me to run as
her lieutenant governor did you do it
did you say yes or no I said no and I
talked about and think about it he did
think I did because you really want
everybody likes to be in the paper but
my manager said you're a comedian and
you got him you got to live and die as a
comedian you can't do something that's a
stunt as a comic you just can't do it
not that her thing she might have been
sincere but for me it was in Genesis my
manager said that and they kind of get a
new manager no they do they like it
would have I probably would have looked
back on that one
shouldn't have and losses and minuses
climb into the arena you know you're
gonna get beat up some that's the way it
is so you're known as the guy who loves
to live in the headlines the only thing
worse than being talked about is not
being talked to right yeah that is true
my should have done it Roger stone is
not the best guy to go to advice for the
unbiased when it comes to doing media
stunts because you've never shied away
from a media stunt it's better than it
is better to be infamous than never be
famous at all right right that was the
takeaway I got from the Netflix
documentary but right now Kristin Davis
his name is coming up in this thing No
yeah it's very it's very disturbing a
Laney aspire who's with us yes as
friendly as no no Kristin for longer
than I here's I met Kristin after the
Eliot Spitzer scandal Kristin Davis was
running one of the most successful call
girl rings in the world a very high-end
enterprise she was supplying women for
the governor he denies that he's lying
and when the whole thing came down she
went to Rikers and he went back to his
penthouse and then to CNN to host a show
how is that right I don't see how that's
right
so I persuaded her I met her on a radio
show I was really impressed because
she's not only beautiful but she's smart
as hell and she presents well and I said
look I can't think of a better way to
demonstrate the inequities in the in our
judicial system between the way men are
treated and the way women are treated
then run use it as a as a forum to show
people the hope all right I heard you
run yeah and so how do we end up in the
place that we're in now well so she ran
for governor she got kind of screwed in
the ballot process because there were
you draw and she was put on a second
page so hard to find her on the ballot
she handled herself very well in the
debate she debated Andrew Cuomo and the
Republican candidate and so on she's
been a friend of mine for a little less
than ten years I guess and she's worked
for me on and off mostly doing research
IT stuff and so on so last Friday
she got a subpoena from the special
counsels office and the irony of that is
that during the entire year of 2015 she
was incarcerated yep and during most of
2016 she was pregnant and in a halfway
house she did not come to work for me
although I paid her in December of 2016
is because it was Christmas and she
needed it she didn't come to work for me
until January 17 so she's not even there
through the whole period of the
gestation or execution of the Trump
campaign now anyway I would've done a
very poor job as lieutenant governor's I
would have done a poor job do you think
during the debates I would have hurt the
cause how now do you think that they're
trying to get to her to try to hurt you
it's hard to say what here's what we do
know she doesn't have any knowledge of
Russian collusion you do no I do not how
okay well she doesn't have any knowledge
of WikiLeaks collaboration she doesn't
know anything about the advanced
publication of John Podesta's emails all
of that is nonsense does she know about
your conversations with gusenberg
if she read about the meals cause the
conversations that are pumped entirely
public and okay knock us those what do
you think they want with her I haven't
had the slightest idea because they're
obviously probably going to her to try
to bump somebody else into doing
something or to make somebody else
concerned she's I feel like they're
trying to make Roger can see I think
it's just desperate move to get to Roger
yeah I think they're definitely trying
to get to Roger it's desperate and it's
harassment and she's a single parent
trying to make her way she's opening up
a beauty business for the art nails this
month and this whole thing is put her in
the rears you know she had to get her
lawyer so that's why we started a
website and a fundraiser for her called
Kristin Davis legal fund calm now you
and Kristin must have been pretty
shocked when this started to go down cuz
it seems like Kristin has kind of been
out of that world for a while paid her
debt to society remade her life she's
been laying low right why does she
deserve this she doesn't know anything
of any value right this is supposed to
be about Russian collusion in the 2016
election she doesn't know anything about
that
either do i yes she had access to my
office she was working for me on and off
for a 10-year period but not during the
relevant period so they just want to see
they're just kind of took a fishing
expedition they just want to see hey
maybe she saw something or said
something that can get us more access
for something that can or gonna make
Roger sweat I hit and you know hitting
his friends where it hurts
look she's a she's won a hard-boiled
lady she's been through the system and
she's got a pretty good grasp of it I'm
sure she'll do well in her testimony but
I can't even talk to her about it yeah
because there's a matter of legality
yeah oh you know if I can talk to her
but I can't talk to her specifically
about her testimony because this will be
viewed is you know
tam-tam and where is the what cuz she's
this is tough for her financially
where's the website that people can help
her it's Kristin Davis legal fund calm
yeah cause that's kind of helping we
just started there two eyes in Christian
Kri STI in Christian Davis this is kind
of nuts it's one thing to watch this
whole circus play itself out with all
the participants to me it seems kind of
crazy to watch somebody it feels like
I'm watching somebody get kind of
dragged into this
circus that's why I kind of feel her for
her legal fees will be a minimum of
fifteen thousand dollars could be twenty
man has to know she's paying a lawyer
you know eight hundred bucks an hour
yeah I don't have that kind of scratch
uh who does yeah I don't know and Plus
while she's running around doing this
she needs to have you know child care
for right her son and she can't be
dragging him to Washington and all the
stuff her son who by the way is my
godson and my god and we'll be President
in the United States you think the son
will be the Carter not if he has
anything to do with you you're nothing
but now let me go Victor we're talking
about before we're talking about like
the media and everything
who at Fox News is anti Trump you're
saying like the same way like I would
look at CNN and MSNBC Shep Smith comes
to mind Shep Smith is is Daisy not a
trend rips off of him it's so obvious
yeah but I mean the whole line up in and
around Shep Smith is pretty in favor of
Trump the morning show clearly likes
jump all the evening shows like you're
right there are somewhere
journalists there but I wanted to ask
you about Michael Cohen do you think
that how is all of this kind of
spiraling out of control like I was the
attorney how is all of this coming apart
I think the issue I think the issue here
is about money as it always is so
Michael cone goes out and he hires a
blue chip the New York law firm to read
through every document to listen to
every tape of that all this material he
has and who knows what six hundred
dollars an hour perhaps so his legal
bills I'm told have reached five million
dollars and already yes and he does not
have five million dollars or if he does
have it he's not willing to spend it so
he has gone to the trumps for assistance
and the trumps can't help him even if
they were sympathetic it would look
improper it would be improper so they
can't help him he never worked for the
campaign's therefore he's not eligible
to get money from the trust that was set
up to help people like Hope Hicks and
others who fell into the Muller you know
juggernaut path so he's very angry that
he is not getting any help on his legal
fees I think that's his motivation do
you think it's a mistake to not give him
help as far as now you've turned this
guy against you we don't know what he
has if he doesn't have more than what he
played in that one tape for him to say I
was with the president and he knew about
the Donald Jr Russian lawyer meeting in
advance because I heard it and he said
so but no other corroborating
information no document no tape
it's just his word I mean I don't think
that she is the word of a former
personal attorney considered hire or or
or they say well he's just trying to he
has other motives I would i if is if a
matter involving him ever got to trial
my guess is that the opposing counsel
would point to other lies that he's told
and therefore you know project that this
one is to I just don't think he's all
that credible look he wanted very badly
to be in the campaign but let me ask you
said it's about money what sir under
what scenario would he get his legal
bills paid for now that he's gone down
this road he's not going to get them
paid now I don't think he was ever going
to get them paid because you have to
avoid
the appearance that you're somehow
bribing him okay I mean has what he has
it's either significant or it is not but
it is driven him into the clutches of
lanny davis who let's face it hasn't
gotten much face time lately so he's got
to be fairly happy land he's not a bad
fellow i bumped into him in the green
rooms he's not a lawyer right not the
kind you go to court with he's a talking
head what was this one of those things
where the government will will the
government if he gives them what they
want pay his legal bills no they won't
know so he believed my house that way
can I'm like whatever what's his
motivation then right like if it's just
angry now he's making an enemy of the
president it's probably not a smart move
so what if he has a financial motivation
how is he gonna get financially
compensated what scenario gets him some
of that money back I can't see any
scenario in which but I'm not an
attorney but I don't believe there's any
way to get his money back now your guy
Paul Manafort is going on trial right
yes now are you still in contact with
him like you solve a relationship with
him cause we're still certainly
fractious thieves yeah isn't uh sure as
my wedding thick as thieves is not
exactly the terminal every American
should be concerned about the idea that
they can put you in solitary confinement
for 23 hours a day prior to being
convicted of any crime seems like
torture see it seems like a violation of
your First Amendment why is he in
solitary it is alleged that he had tried
that he was involved in witness
tampering the government can't monitor
him of course they can you know Paul you
think he would tamper witnesses his
lawyer says the case is ridiculous
and he's pretty savvy why and he knows
he's being watched so why would he go do
that do you think that there's based on
on the world that you you've seen all
this stuff happen I'm not asking you to
imply guilt on anybody but do you think
that there's a possibility that some of
these people they're usually pretty
savvy are starting to panic because the
the house of cards to forgive a terrible
expression is kind of starting to fall
to collapse or no I understand the
concept meaning would he act in a way
that is out of character like would he
do something that it
responsible right RCT panicking because
all of a sudden they see somebody go to
jail I know it's important to note that
that they're still none of the charges
against him relate to trump with a trump
campaign none so this is not an example
of Russian collusion so to speak right
and he'll have his day in court the
pressure on him is to plead guilty they
don't want to go to trial and the reason
they don't want to go to trial is
because it will reveal that he liked
Carter page was under government
surveillance in an illegal
unconstitutional warrant I see some and
there are three people in this category
the other one is sitting here according
to the New York Times gen Laney yeah in
January 20th 2017 page one the New York
Times says page Mana Fortin Stone were
subject to FISA warrants a FISA warrant
can only be issued on an American
citizen if you're actively involved in
espionage on behalf of a foreign
government against the United States I
certainly wasn't manna for it was it and
I don't believe page was so these FISA
warrants were used for political reasons
this is ten times worse than water are
you nervous that it's going to get I'm
not gonna say worse for you but get more
financially involved where you are
nervous would be the wrong room I don't
get nervous I make other people nervous
this is gonna cost a fortune
this will be the Battle of all time
again coming up empty-handed
in terms of Russian collusion or
WikiLeaks collaboration or this nonsense
regarding Podesta's devastatingly
embarrassing emails could a special
prosecutor go out and conjure up some
other offense sure I do think people
will see through it they will see that
this is a vendetta and I'm being
persecuted for my support of Trump why
if if you're innocent I have no reason
to believe you're not you've told us
many times and you've kind of unshakably
told us the same things every time you
come in why do they have such a hard-on
for getting you well I wrote a book
called the Clintons war on women okay
because I spent most of the campaign
punking liberals and Democrats on my
Twitter feed which was very successful
do you miss being on Twitter sometimes I
do sometimes I don't I I kind of have a
lot of respect for Maggie Haberman in
the New York
she announced a backup about a week ago
she was leaving it cuz it's just become
a mud fight it's you know it's all it's
all become broad-based personal you
involved you didn't help to deter it
from becoming a mud fight I think I turn
a phrase
you know said things on Twitter that I
apologize for that were you under were
you drinking or anything or like we you
just I had a couple what you call the
two martini tweets yeah a couple of
cocktails whose cam no so so for example
did I say that in a navara in a Navarro
of CNN was borderline [ __ ] yes do I
regret that or retract it no you don't I
do even with the R word in there I do
not you know we don't do the R word
anymore that's a thing I understand but
you think that that's true what you said
yes oh wow honey yes you gotta go you
said a lot of upset people you know what
are you basing that on this is having
better I said you know what I really
don't like tell me the way she abuses
little people so who do you mean like
remaining like the the makeup people the
hair people gaffers the technicians talk
to anybody are you for CNN and they say
she's a diva she treats them like
they're garbage these people work too we
can edit widgets you're a guy who really
doesn't you know you've said a lot of
things and upset people and you don't
seem to care at what point do you
realize like oh okay that one's a
problem like what happen your life who
calls you and you go when that person
tells me that's the problem
the wife is a pretty good arbiter of
these things but you know I don't think
anybody among us is perfect and doesn't
make mistake so I look at the tweet and
I say well somebody lag this over to
Media Matters America so they can twist
it the president also I would disi a
resident yeah we got this hard yeah her
Media Matters by order a lot could rip
it apart line by line but why bother
right right media marriage they just did
all Rocco
guy's a phony half that stuff I never
said it's just but once it's on the
internet you see becomes a factoid
that's fake knows
I see who's the guy in the president's
life because he after the
Hooten press conference he comes back
and and you know he's very very good at
staying by his points and not allowing
the criticism to make him reverse
himself but he did reverse himself when
he came back and I'm like who is it in
his life that can call him and say look
that was incorrect like everyone has to
have a person that they value like that
who like when that person tells you
something you hear it he's very much his
own man
and although I still think that he seeks
a lot of advice from a broad
cross-section of people he works the
phone like no president since LBJ
constantly on the phone he is also
marches very much to his own drummer so
just because he solicits your advice
doesn't mean he will take it I the only
person in his life who I think meets
that criteria is Melania really yes
his wife yes she's very influential she
very very very very rarely to my
knowledge weighs in on political matters
it's not her thing but she'll also be
terribly blunt my theory and I have no
idea you'd know better than me is that
she does not like him very much and is
very miserable being the first lady
that's just what her body language says
to me I don't think she ever wanted him
to run for president mm-hmm she she
thought he of something he had to get
out of his system because he felt
strongly about it
the president thought he would lose
right it was an improbable victory the
odds were overwhelmingly against him
that was the conventional wisdom opposed
to she was supportive of the campaign
she's been supportive of his presidency
but I don't think she wanted to move to
Washington I don't think she wanted to
take Baron out of school I think she
liked her life in New York so I think
she's bearing this this is not what she
wanted but now it's a guy like Trump who
like you know he has an ego I think even
you could admit that did really does he
does he resent at all that his wife
would think that you're not gonna win
because I would imagine that Donald
thought he was gonna win because see
I've heard he didn't think he was gonna
win I've heard that he felt like at one
point maybe it began to believe it but
I'd heard that he thought that like
there's no way this is gonna happen I
think it's the other way around in other
words I think he pretty consistently
thought that he would win
I think his confidence that he could win
grew mostly on the basis of anecdotal
information you go to Michigan for a
campaign rally and 30,000 people show up
and Hillary has a rally and 200 people
show up it's an indicator of something
then does he get upset that his wife
doesn't think he's gonna win no because
I think at the very end when you had the
New York Times statistician saying
there's a 90% chance of a Hillary
victory I think at the very end he had a
note of caution where he said to his
wife look I don't know how this is gonna
go we could win we could lose you have
to be ready for both I so I think for an
epithet c'n his confidence may have been
waned shaken sure all the pundits all
the experts are saying you can't win but
generally speaking I think he this idea
that he didn't want to win is completely
false do you think it hurts him that the
New York Times has such a hatred for him
I mean again he's sort of new york i and
the new or no I think it helps him
because people hate the New York Times
so you don't think it bothers my prepare
again elitists go I mean Trump voters
are reading the New York Post yeah and
the Daily News : the Daily News is in
trouble - oh they laid off a bunch of
half there for tons of people yeah oh
this is the beauty of twitter twitter
for Trump is like owning a newspaper
without the debt yeah I mean Mort
Zuckerman should sell The Daily News and
get himself a Twitter account you want
cheap yeah that is true and people and
plus you want to read the paper
cigarette I want to I want to hear a
news that is a day old and already 24
hours irrelevant reading the paper just
doesn't feel the same anymore also they
don't because The Daily News attempts in
their editorial page and in their
coverage to seem like the New York Times
that niche is felled snotty elitist
liberal we already got that area cover
right you know The Daily News was
traditionally the working people's part
newspaper and they have kind of lost
their way the post has filled that gap
let me ask you some of the stuff about
this Media Matters article because I'm
very curious now do you back this
article or no the article is called
Roger stone has
or contradicted himself regarding Russia
probe matters on countless occasions
okay how about this I'll just give me a
paper cut
did you have a meeting with a Russian
national about the Trump campaign I had
a meeting with an FBI informant who was
sent in to compromise me on May 16th yes
I've been very clear about that did you
ever say that you never had any contact
with the action yes because I admitted
that the meeting that was about 20
minutes long I didn't remember the guys
name was greenberg by the way not
exactly a Russian name so I recalled
this only when the special counsels
office brought it up with Michael Caputo
let's look at the facts they send me a
guy who's a Russian national but he's in
the country on an informants visa he's a
violent criminal who did time for gun
crimes in Russia
and he's been he's got nine such visas
he comes to me and through a friend and
says I have information on Hillary
Clinton that could be very damaging and
you can have it for two million dollars
you came I said I don't have two million
dollars see Jim and Sam maybe they've
got I don't have two million dollars but
even if I did I wouldn't buy information
from you and he laughs and says to me
it's not your money I want its Trump's
money ah no I think the House
Intelligence Committee is very anxious
now to figure out who was mr. Greenberg
did Peter Strock sent him he's
undeniably a forget about that meeting
though that's that's like a scandalous
meeting 20 of my life is rather busy and
a presidential campaign is a is
all-consuming it wouldn't it be one of
those things that stuck in the back of
your mind like I know there's
information no because people come to
you all the time with something they
want to tell you something I want to
sell you something they want to give you
if you if you just tell Trump to say
this he'll win I mean it's that
conversation is not as atypical for you
and she'll stick out I was not told
prior to meeting him he was a Russian
national when I met with him he had a
thick Eastern European action ask him
where he came from so he didn't tell you
that he was a Russian national
the Mamoon din the phony Media Matters
article is nothing improper or legal
happens at the meeting or as a result of
the meeting so what reason would I have
to dissemble or forget to have it I just
forgot how about and I updated my
testimony and a letter from my attorneys
how about the claim that you at one
point said because you've said you know
100 times I feel like every time you've
been on we've asked you about Julian
Assange and a hundred times you've
explained it and and it's been pretty
consistent but what about this other
claim that at one point you said you had
a high ranking mutual friend yes that
you'd then and that that person yes
became somebody you communicate yes with
Julian Assange through yes that's true
well through what who I communicated
with WikiLeaks through yes that is true
and I testified to that effect under
oath before the House Intelligence
Committee okay so while you didn't speak
directly to WikiLeaks correct you spoke
through person okay all right now we're
getting somewhere right now I'm sorry
this kind of falls under the tactic of
old news look this is something that
this has been out there saying well
there's a there's a narrative here stone
worked with the Russians to hack the DNC
then he took the material which he got
from the Russians and he gave it to a
Julian Assange be WikiLeaks see Donald
Trump or D the Trump campaign it's
completely false I noticed it's an
article of faith because of the accuracy
of my predictions on Twitter and on the
circus with HBO but it's there's just no
evidence to prove not an iota of that
can be proved not a bit of it what did
you a WikiLeaks talk about through that
guy we did we I asked them for well
let's back up a size said on June 1st on
CNN he had a treasure trove of
information on Hillary that he would
drop you're like dope she said he's
devastating information fabulous I asked
my friend two questions is it true and
when do you think this might happen
I'm strong yes evidently it is true and
I'm told October 1st now if you had
asked what is the information would that
be considered inappropriate question I
don't think he would have known I don't
think they would have told you because
they're not going to leak their own
story in advance no but I mean would
that question have been Hugh
centered more inappropriate than the
other tool ago now you're actually
seeking information again me and a
thousand other journalists it's not a
crime to talk to Julian Assange or
WikiLeaks they do the same thing the New
York Times does but I had no advance
notice of the source or content of their
disclosures only that they were coming
and I was told October 1st in the end
they came a little later than that so
how are they trying to tie you in with
it because you asked two questions uh
because it is alleged that Assange is a
Russian asset which he's not so they
need to prove that in court first here's
how the intelligence services work they
say something over and over and over
again and they think that makes it a
fact I'll give you an example Lee Harvey
Oswald killed Kennedy and he acted alone
I heard that agree right yeah but it's
not true oh the point is you can just
keep saying it turn it into fact right
it becomes a factoid you know the idea
that Assange works for the Russians he
denies it and they haven't proved it
when the intelligence services tell you
something is their assessment your
that's when your [ __ ] detector
should go off that means they don't know
anything right that's not a fact that's
what they want you to think well that's
what they think however on a side I do
have to read your book because I always
believed in conspiracy and I do think
Oswald acted alone but I have to read
your book definitely not yeah okay the
case against LBJ will blow your mind
okay what do you think of this who is
America show Sacha Baron Cohen's new
show on Showtime it's really ruffling a
lot of feathers with some of you
certainly got it certainly gotten enough
coverage a lot of coverage a lot of it
is funny though well what it shows me is
that certain conservatives are so
ignorant of the pop culture that they
couldn't figure out they were being set
up so you you were you at all insulted
that you were not asked to be on the
show I think I would have gone for it
you don't think they could I probably
knew they couldn't get it no foul how
great would it be he doesn't like dress
up in an outfit and see if I can Punk
him yeah how wonderful though would it
be for all of us if like Rodgers saying
this now and doesn't realize that he
already hated you and he pops up on like
Episode six or something
only guy the only guy who they who would
they kind of failed to entrap was
congressman Matt Gaetz we're learning
from Florida and it's because he's
cognizant to the pop culture he think I
seen about ten seconds did they get your
joy more bear and cone who's that boy I
don't know that boy I mean right is no
clue they they nail Roy anymore Bernie
Sanders did not know he was on a Sacha
Baron Cohen she sure he didn't he didn't
take the bait but he didn't you know he
didn't throw him out like that guy in
the gun store like he walked in and
tried to do the skit in the gun store
and there's like your borah surveillance
footage as your Borah get out it some
guys are just they don't know they're
being trolled but they're just media
savvy enough to know like nom like the
fact that the guy would drop the n-bomb
and then put his put his ass down for it
when there's a camera in the room yeah
regardless of who would they say it's
for it it's crazy [ __ ] but you think
it's a funny show I haven't seen the
show you so I can have you seen that
scene i but there's a tiny out only read
about it very funny very very funny to
watch that it's an elected official with
his hiney out we once we watch that is
no no it official anymore
no not a reason but he's like that's
right Mary anyway so he wasn't gonna be
around much longer but he decided not to
stick around any long he said he was
going to and then somebody when the
governor pins a tweet that you're
despicable you probably got right oh by
the way what do you think is Sheldon
Silver going going to jail for seven
years I was not surprised that he was
reconvicted I'm very hazy guy that was
[ __ ] the UFC for a long time so happy
to see how Albany is a cesspool a mad
working fear I've worked in 35 roughly
of the 50 states this is the single most
corrupt mismanaged state in the country
without any question why it's hard to
understand I think that the the multiple
party thing is where it starts in other
words the fact that you can be the
nominee of the Republican and
conservative party or the Democrat and
the Working Families Party that opens
the door to all kinds of horse trading
which I just think it's a bad idea
even though I love the New York State
conservative party I also love my
libertarians out there but I think the
cross endorsement thing is a bad idea if
they want to run their own candidates
they should but running the same
candidate the major parties that opens a
door I think to
a lot of horse trading also you know
it's a it's an incredibly blue state so
lack of competition believe breeds
contempt and arrogance and corruption
when one party's intro in in charge for
too long regardless of which party it is
they get arrogant and they get sloppy
yeah whether or not you're guilty have
you thought about this the vision we've
seen so many of these documentaries
right where people who aren't even
they're not guilty they go to jail
anyway once you get accused of a crime
once you're on trial there's always that
risk right have you given any thought to
the idea that there's this risk that you
might end up in jail look for my new
book framed the Rogers so you turn it
into an opportunity I think I've been
very clear people keep saying to me do
you expect to be indicted no but I could
be framed I could be railroaded I
certainly won't go quietly
go look up the Abbie Hoffman trial
during the Vietnam War
hmm you get some idea what this will be
our people like with J Edgar Hoover
people were scared they were almost more
scared of him dead than alive because of
all the files he had they don't know
where everything was kept they didn't
know what he had told to who now do you
think people have the same concerns
about you that you know so much about so
many people that a lot of people would
be nervous
first of all let's be completely clear
I've never been a religious right
conservative never been a moral majority
conservative I'm a freak oh yeah yeah
you know sure I'm very naughty boy if
you're not my thing I'm a firm believer
in the use of medicinal marijuana you
like that you know so but I'm not
claiming to be a purist see the crime I
think is hypocrisy I never had a problem
with Spitzer going call girls just don't
bust other guys for going to cry right
while you're doing it right in other
words prostitution my view should be
legal licensed by the state the you know
with a review from the Health Board
maybe a little tax as opposed to being
underground where women get beat up and
where women are being held against their
will and so on so my private life which
FBI agents seem to be very centered on
in other words at least now 10 of my
current
former associates or employees had been
questioned by the FBI
what's the relevance of does he drink
does he smoke marijuana does he have
girlfriends how does he get along with
his wife they showed them pictures of
Kristin Davis's baby and say is this
right because they won't they won't
embarrass you
oh yeah that was a rumor that was going
around for a while that the Kristin's
son was his but just wild because I feel
like the Roger stone personal life sort
of this is what he's really up to
that was like decades ago but that was
already we did that that that too I
think it seems like when you look at the
history of Roger stone your personal
life being exposed and the swinger stuff
coming out and all that stuff kind of
created the version of Roger stone that
we see today it strikes me as difficult
to embarrass you using details of your
personal life unless you've got some
kind of insane skeletons that we don't
already know about I think I've been
very clear when it comes to sex I'm
trisexual I've tried it all that's yes
you have what have you tried to get
didn't like we won't get is the spice of
life now you still like that as a I'm a
bit older and wiser now but I was much
wilder in my younger days still a freak
though a gentleman to be otherwise sure
is the point it knows it's the hypocrisy
that gets you yeah right if you pretend
to be something in clean-cut and you're
attacking people for something that
you're saying sheriff of Wall Street was
you know breaking a law that was his
problem was hypocrisy